would you want to marry a virgin
I wouldn't mind you wouldn't mind
marrying a person you want to like tell
them what to do I wouldn't mind because
it's not it's not an issue for me if he
ticks every single box and then it turns
out he's a virgin to me I wouldn't I
wouldn't be fast could you name could
you name five of your boxes
name five of my boxes yeah so
ambitious God-fearing like prayerful
um
loyal as well
funny sort of sense of humor and
can't think of a fifth one when you say
ambitious is there a dollar amount no
ambitious like driven wanting something
for himself and not just so if he's
making how old are you so you're 31 35
35 how old would you date
the oldest I would date yeah
probably 40. so if he's 40 and he still
makes 30 000 I don't know the conversion
like 30 000 US Dollars which would be
like 20 20 like 20 000 20 000 pounds
would you be cool with that he's 40 he
said time to get there
if he's if he's trying to get somewhere
and he's not just what if he gets what
if he gets nowhere
well because I'd I'd sense that he's not
ambitious and it would put me off right
but I think like a lot of times it's
kind of disingenuous to guys because
girls will say there's no price but you
you have one in your head and there is a
price he there has to be working towards
that like towards it or there but if he
doesn't get there within a certain
amount of time your ghost you're gone no
but you can't really put a time frame on
I'm giving you a time to become
successful but no I'm saying um you
might not know Urban to want to get
there and actively trying to get there
does that make sense right you might not
know it like con like you might not have
thought about it but like in some level
you're not going to date a bum forever
so if he if he's but I wouldn't have if
he's a bum and he's not ambitious I
wouldn't be attracted to him yeah yeah
but I'm saying there's a there's a
dollar there's a minimum dollar
okay would you date a guy that's
homeless with no job I wouldn't meet a
guy that's homeless in my job where
would I meet you you pass them every day
but why would I approach
how would that work right but I'm saying
you there's a minimum requirement you
have yes not just related to like is
that a bad thing no it's not a bad thing
I don't think I don't think we should
date bombs yeah I'm saying like you're
avoiding the question what was the
question what's the minimum amount of
money you need a guy to make
I don't know more than me I don't know
it's the same as me or more okay what's
roughly you don't have to
I don't want to say my how much I make
but the same as me or more that's you
can't make less than you right basically
yeah okay why not well I'm not saying he
can't but I would prefer I'm saying what
I prefer is if he was the same level as
me or make him more if he's making less
a bit less and actively trying to
progress within his career then there's
nothing wrong with that cancer start
something he said about the boxes
what are your boxes and it was the
Virgin I mean you said you'd take on a
virgin virgin wasn't in the book no she
said she said what are your boxes when
he said about yeah she no woman ever
says sex
if it was a man wouldn't that be one of
your boxes
you know you said that everywhere and
you take your boxes yeah as a man
wouldn't sex be one of your top boxes
I'm just asking asking would I marry a
virgin
you know you said ever man ever woman
takes all your boxes right isn't sex one
of your boxes
um do you think did you never happen
could you have a happy relationship
without having that box sticks without
having sex or without having good sex
good sex
yeah I could still have a pretty
successful relationship not me yeah
I don't believe you yeah I mean look I
know that's one of my main boxes no no
no because I'm saying everybody's
talking about oh I want to be nice or
compatible
but you won't know that until you have
sex with him
that's why when women say they want to
have a virgin to me
because I ain't got time if I'm a virgin
he's a virgin fine but I am not gonna go
and pick up a virgin
F6 is one of my boxes and sex is one of
my boxes it should be a man's box too
because if you're not getting good sex
on your woman go elsewhere same thing
for women I'm sorry but how could that's
when they got seckless marriages out
there yes how can you be having like you
be oh yeah I'm happy well sex is not one
of my boxes she knows that sex ain't one
of your boxes the window six is gone
what are you gonna do then say Oh but I
like her personality
see every question do you think it's
fair for a woman to expect monogamy from
men if they gave their best years to
another man
Umi yeah I like it I start Angie you
want to start he's he's a little nervous
no give your best to the one you got and
if you can't give me your best and he's
going elsewhere
then you can't blame him I'm sorry but
like I said before no man no man no
woman should put up with bad sex and if
a man is having bad sex it's the woman's
fault
it's the woman's fault because if you
get a man a male virgin and a woman
he's gonna have bad sex anyway she's
gonna teach him rubbish just to keep him
down there but if you get a man who's
had lots of sex and a virgin he's gonna
teach you everything he knows to make
sure that she can perform properly so as
far as I'm concerned if you're with
somebody and you're not getting good sex
from them and I'm talking about making
love because when audiences making up
making up that's the little Christmas
birthdays whatever minutes when I have
sex after sex ain't good get rid because
I'm sorry but there's too many men out
there having sex as relationships and
it's wrong all these feelings about oh I
want the personality I want this and
that why doesn't that work the other way
you said that the man can teach the
virgin woman how to have good sex but
why can't the woman who's had a lot of
sex teach the Virgin how to have kids
why is it not well I just I just think
if women were lined up for virgins then
one out of three men wouldn't be virgins
wait say again if women were lined up to
date virgins if that was true then one
out of three men wouldn't be virgins
okay one out of three men under 30
haven't had sex in the past year or are
virgins one out of every three men so
like if women wanted virgins they're
there
but how would you know
I still think that falls into that how
much confidence she was sorry sorry that
she was talking about earlier with a man
approaching you nobody was talking
earlier and he mentioned confidence that
confidence comes from experience of
women over time so that same confident
guy you want to approach you he's not
going to get that confidence unless he's
had that previous experience including
sexual so even this guy with this low
body count that's not the same sort of
guy confidence like I don't think it's
like just related to sex obviously yeah
if you add a hard you know multiple
women like you had a lot of experience
you're probably gonna be a tiny bit more
confident but I think like you know how
do you acting bad this kind of even you
know inside you or you have it or not
like it's not really about how many more
directions the men can bring it out of
you a man can bring it out of a woman
but how often does a woman bring it out
of a man is that because you're speaking
from a woman's perspective so you
wouldn't know so I can only speak with
men so I got male friends most I say 99
and my friend a male
they're not getting enough sex and
they're not getting enough sex how they
want it where they want it whenever they
want it and it's a woman that are like
holding these keys of sex like
that's why I can speak from a woman
because there's men out there you can as
a woman that's had ex-partners you can
look at your partners and see where the
women have done them wrong
you can know because the women ain't
teaching them the women are so quick to
open their legs but not their mouth to
say excuse me but mate but what are you
doing down there that's wrong fix up or
this is how you're supposed to do it but
there's too many men there's too many
women out there now having bad sex
because in a men's previous Partners not
teaching him properly
[Music]
um
interesting that's not well I guess I
guess that's a girl but how do you know
it's bad
you must have lots of like pretty nice
baths
no let's say you have to have a lot to
compare it to to know it's bad no no you
can just know how you feel because if
you go and you relax yourself and you
free up and you trust the man that he
knows what you're doing you're gonna
have good sex all the time
um okay what you want to answer the
question
um I mean I personally so like this
might sound controversial but I feel
it's unrealistic to believe a man should
be with one woman okay so I agree that
you know they shouldn't expect it from a
man but I feel like everything comes
down to control so as a man if you
decide you're going to go into a
relationship you have to decide to
control yourself and choose to be
faithful
what if your woman's a freak
what would that what would that do no
she's up for anything with you sexually
yeah you're still gonna go as well it
doesn't matter you're still gonna go
elsewhere if you want to go elsewhere
you're gonna go oh you can have the
perfect woman in the world
if you want to cheat you will cheat it
doesn't matter there's I do not believe
there is anything a woman can do to stop
a man from cheating if he wants to cheat
um
sorry do you agree that not all Menchie
hold it down bro do you agree that not
all men cheat
some men don't
I'm saying not all men cheat yeah that's
fine then
one thing I can I add yeah so one thing
I will say is I think men exercise their
options right so most men
women don't find them attractive and
therefore they don't have options to
exercise and therefore they cannot cheat
whereas the top percentile of men have
options to exercise therefore they can
cheat and if the woman that is with them
feels a type of way wants to leave is
like okay
I'll just add a new girl to the rotation
and he's able to get a plethora of girls
because he's got the option to exercise
his will to cheat
minority that don't no I agree I think
yeah I think you'd agree most do if they
can't yeah if they could but but most
men can't
enough
most men in relationships can't cheat
um so what about you do you think it's
fair that women expect monogamy if they
gave their best years to another man uh
no
um definitely not definitely not what
would you define as a woman's best years
go ahead okay well I'll put that into
the same sort of especially with that
particular male or man usually her
child's dad her first love is usually
that type of person you know he's
usually he's usually got everything else
out of her by the time you've come
across her whatever the scenario is
the world getting the after bits there's
going to be memories of him be it in a
relationship sexual whatever you know
there's going to be especially if
they've got a child there's an imprint
I've seen it loads of times you know
people have broken up they've got for
someone else as soon as the kid dad come
back in the picture gone they're either
sleeping together or they're back
together so if a woman's had her best
years with another male
to me she she's actually his to be
perfectly honest and I find a lot of the
time that there's that one particular
guy is there a certain age that you
would say
it depends what she's kind of done up to
them okay
um but to be fair about sort of like the
mid 30ish then by that point it's like
yeah specifically as many
as many on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible